je demande c'est ce quiz est aujourd'hui
jusqu'à dix buts merci merci et encore
merci je fais cette vidéo pour vous
remercier parce que la campagne de dons
pour l'association petits princes c'est
vraiment super bien passé on a atteint
l'objectif
en seulement quelques jours je dirais
une semaine je me souviens plus
exactement un total de 22 mille 536
euros ont été récoltés
on savait la tâche allait même pas du
fait que l'accusé pas aussi forte
ou plutôt on les applaudit à ses passes
alors c'était une grande perte pour moi
d'organiser une campagne de dons mais
peut-être pour vous c'était aussi une
grande première de données j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas on a réussi à
faire ça tous ensemble et honnêtement
c'est surtout grâce à vous beaucoup plus
calmes oise l'association m'avait
proposé de le rendre visite dans leurs
locaux ce que j'acceptais avec grand
plaisir j'ai rencontré une énorme partie
de l'équipe alors c est essentiellement
constituée de bénévoles ce qui fait
qu'ils sont pas tous là tous les jours
mais croyez moi ils sont vraiment
nombreux qu'ils étaient tous adorables
et je voyais bien que j'aime raconter le
rêve qu'ils ont mis en place pour un
enfant malade y avait des étoiles dans
leurs yeux et est encore émue règles et
sans rappeler un truc qui m'a
impressionné aussi c'est dans une sale
histoire plein plein plein de dossiers
et chaque dossier correspond à un rêve
d'enfant réalisé autant vous dire que
les dossiers il y en a mais je sais pas
combien jamais vu autant de dossiers
concentrer sur deux mètres carrés quoi
quand je suis allé les voir ils avaient
tous un grand sourire et au moment où
j'arrivais tout vent les gens qui me
voyez il disait est ce que c'est lui ou
pas
le beau linge ce goût des cas piqueteurs
de chiens mais ils avaient tous entendu
parler de cette campagne de dons ils
étaient tous autant sur les fesses que
moi je n'étais quand j'ai vu comment
vous avez joué le jeu c'est vraiment un
truc de dingue on a fait aussi une sorte
de remise de chèques officielle pour
qu'il prenne une photo etc
et d'ailleurs on peut le dire visuel
saout ici avec ma main pour dire vous
devriez être à ma place si chacun
d'entre vous devraient être à côté de
moi ici derrière ce chèque est ce qui
est drôle c'est que si on regarde bien
je suis quasiment la seule personne à
regarder ma caméra tout le monde regarde
et l'appareil photo de l'autre personne
est du coup en voyons c'est un montage
bus sortie carrément seul voilà c'est un
peu comme ça sur mon siège
enfin bref merci les gens merci vous
avez fait un truc de dingue tous
ensemble on a montré finalement au monde
que on est capable de faire autre chose
que de faire des vidéos ou de regarder
des vidéos ou jouer aux jeux vidéo
franchement c'est incroyable j'ai encore
du mal à réaliser qu'on atteint
l'objectif de 20000 euros en seulement
quelques jours
merci juste merci à vous allez détester
ce mot dans la rue tu es quelqu'un dès
que vous allez entendre merci des
barbouzes l arrivée vers la mecque faire
tu te dis quoi télé quoi
pour ce qui est des contributions j'ai
du retard mais ne vous en faites pas il
arrive seulement je suis le seul à gérer
tout ça et ça m'a mis énormément de
temps rien qu'à faire cette foutue liste
avec tous les e-mails des personnes à
qui je dois demander si et ça enfin bref
ça arrive pas de panique d'ailleurs on a
une qui arrive tout juste à la fin de
cette vidéo
en tout cas encore merci on refera sa
dans six mois un an trois mois j'en sais
rien mais croyez-moi on leur fera parce
que c'est quelque chose d'incroyable
soyez tous fiers de vous que vous ayez
participer à cette campagne de dons
d'une manière ou d'une autre
encore une fois merci au nom de toute
l'équipe de l'association petits princes
merci et je vous dis à très bientôt de
nouvelles vidéo chat au monde pis
m
non